Does vitamin E increase estrogen? I have estrogen-positive breast cancer.
Vitamin E has been shown to be actually helpful in breast cancer.
Matter of fact, higher dose, even the
the top cause for all, vitamin E can be a can function in just exactly what I was talking about
before in a oxidative mode for breast cancer. In fact, I just saw several studies a few
months ago about high dose delta-tocoltrino and high dose alpha and mixed tocophurals for
breast cancer showing that it increases oxidative stress to breast cancer cells and spares all
healthy cells so it could be a nice adjunctive therapy. Of course, most of the studies with
nutrients are studies that are done concurrently with chemotherapy just so you know.
It's hard to get very many studies approved at least in the United States in recent years that are
going to be for specific nutrients and cancer without them being combined with chemotherapy.
So usually they're looking for does curcumin increase the efficacy of chemotherapy? Well, that's what
let's say if the study showed, you know, 100 women taking chemotherapy and then another 100
men taking chemotherapy plus curcumin and the ones that took the group that took chemotherapy plus
curcumin had a better success rate than they're going to give the credit to the chemotherapy
that the curcumin actually helps the chemotherapy work better instead of that the curcumin actually killed
the cancer cells. Well, who cares? I mean, it's just what it is. I mean, we are capitalistic society driven
by money governed by who has the most money and it happens to be the pharmaceutical companies right now.
So the studies that I saw were vitamin E, both the Toconferols and Tocotranols,
with breast cancer, they were very very positive. So I would not say that you have to worry about
vitamin E increasing estrogen with the ER positive cancer given even just that study.
Again, I would say if you do have cancer and you are doing vitamin E, make sure you're not doing
antioxidants. It's very common that I see a person doing, you know, high dose antioxidants because
they're maybe their carpractor or nutritious told them to do that. Well, you have cancer. Well,
antioxidants help reduce the risk of cancer. So if you have cancer, you better take a whole bunch
of antioxidants and again, that's not really the right thought process. Well, you have cancer, you want
to increase oxidative stress to kill those cancer cells.